Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
"La guerre des âges
ou le déni du vieillissement".
La société française,
comme la plupart
des sociétés européennes,
chacune avec ses spécificités,
est constituée d'un archipel
de communautés,
un archipel
de situations familiales,
religieuses et territoriales,
de modes de vie distincts,
de valeurs qui s'entremêlent
et, parfois, s'entrechoquent,
ce qui fait le sel et le poivre
d'un vivre-ensemble
qui doit s'adapter
aux transformations
et aux mutations climatiques,
technologiques et socioculturelles,
avec le risque inhérent
à la société de consommation,
où tout passe
dans le commerce,
selon Marx,
où le rêve
a disparu,
selon Freud,
avec aussi le déni démographique
d'une société
qui tend infailliblement
vers le vieillissement,
avec, certes,
des limites biologiques,
mais que l'espérance de vie
prolonge toutefois
avec les aléas du grand âge.
Sommes-nous préparés
à cette transition démographique
qui bouleverse
tous les compartiments
socio-économiques,
culturels et sanitaires
liés au vieillissement ?
De nombreux projets de loi,
mais pas
de véritable loi sur le grand âge,
parce que ça coûterait
trop cher
ou, plus cyniquement,
parce que le sujet,
par trop consensuel,
ne cliverait pas politiquement ?
C'est ce dont nous allons discuter
avec mes invités,
mais il est une autre priorité
que nous examinerons aussi
et qui a trait
au bouleversement anthropologique
d'une société moderne
qui oublie ses vieux
en se privant du monde d'avant,
des simples choses de la vie
si chères à Georges Perec,
de la part intime
de notre identité passée
et de tous ces petits détails
rendus insignifiants
par l'hypermodernité
et qui nous permettent de donner
de la vie à la vie.
Pour en parler,
je vous présente mes invités.
Jérôme Guedj,
vous êtes député de l'Essonne,
conseiller régional
d'Ile-de-France.
Juliette Méadel,
vous êtes
ancienne ministre.
Vous êtes élue à Montrouge
et présidente
de L'Avenir n'attend pas.
Hervé Le Bras,
vous êtes démographe et essayiste.
Jean-Pierre Michel, vous êtes
professeur des universités,
notamment en Suisse,
et membre
de l'Académie nationale
de médecine.
Dans votre rapport,
Jérôme Guedj, vous distinguez
trois catégories
parmi les personnes âgées
de plus de 60 ans :
celles qui sont autonomes,
en somme, en bonne santé,
celles qui sont fragiles
et qui nécessitent
un accompagnement
et les personnes âgées
dépendantes.
Au total, plus de 20 %
et, si on en croit
les statistiques,
30 % en 2050.
Avec des besoins quantitatifs
et qualitatifs aussi massifs,
nécessaires
par les situations rencontrées,
comment faire en attendant
cette loi du grand âge
qui est programmée pour 2024 ?
-D'abord, il faut regarder le sujet.
Le problème qu'on a...
La démographie, et je parle
sous le couvert d'Hervé Le Bras,
est tonitruante
dans les informations
qu'elle nous fournit.
S'il y a bien un phénomène
totalement prévisible,
c'est celui du vieillissement
de la population.
C'est vrai que
nous sommes entrés
dans une période de massification,
de triple massification
du vieillissement.
Les trois catégories mentionnées,
je les ai empruntées
aux gériatres.
C'est une pyramide
qui est celle
de la robustesse,
des fragilités
et de la perte d'autonomie.
On peut y mettre...
-Ca s'entremêle.
-...des bornes d'âge
qui ne veulent pas dire grand-chose.
On peut être en situation
de fragilité à 62 ou 63 ans,
parce qu'on a une pathologie,
parce qu'on a eu une carrière
avec un métier pénible.
Pour schématiser,
mettons quelques bornes d'âge
pour bien comprendre que,
quand on parle de vieillissement
et de vieillesse,
c'est une kyrielle
de situations aussi différentes
que celles qui existent
entre 0 et 20 ans.
Quel est le point commun
entre un nourrisson
accueilli par la PMI
et un jeune en insertion
professionnelle,
accompagné par une mission locale ?
C'est un peu pareil
pour les personnes âgées.
Le retraité actif,
juste après la fin...
Après sa sortie
du marché du travail,
il a du temps.
Il est plutôt en bonne santé.
Il est sollicité
par sa famille.
Chaque semaine, les personnes âgées
font autant de garde d'enfants
que l'ensemble
des services publics et privés
de crèches ou de nounous.
Ils participent
à la vie associative.
Sans retraités,
aucune association ne tournerait.
Ca, c'est la question
de l'utilité sociale
de la place
des personnes âgées.
Et puis - mettons une date -
après 75-80 ans,
c'est l'âge des fragilités.
Là, je parle sous le couvert
du médecin.
La physiologie fait
qu'on va avoir
des fragilités
physiques ou psychiques
liées à l'âge.
Là, se noue le coeur du défi.
Comment on fait
pour que ces fragilités
ne basculent pas
dans la pointe de la pyramide,
qui est la perte d'autonomie,
la dépendance,
qui, pour le coup,
concerne
une minorité
de personnes âgées ?
C'est pas un cheminement linéaire.
Je termine par là.
L'enjeu
des politiques publiques
- c'est ce qui m'intéresse -
face à ces défis,
c'est de faire en sorte que,
grâce à la prévention
et à l'adaptation de la société
au vieillissement,
on accompagne les fragilités,
on les intègre,
on les voie,
pour limiter les situations
de perte d'autonomie
et, quand elles surviennent,
avoir des réponses qui sont
à la hauteur.
-Merci. Hervé Le Bras,
j'allais dire que
vous êtes le matheux,
le démographe,
le statisticien.
Un mot simplement
sur cette trinité.
Vous y croyez, vous,
à cette trinité ?
Laïque, bien entendu.
Ils rient.
-Je suis d'accord
avec Jérôme Guedj.
Peut-être que...
La petite nuance que j'aurais,
c'est que,
au fil du temps,
avec le vieillissement,
les âges de séparation
ont bougé.
Il faut se souvenir que,
au 19e siècle, un vieillard...
Chez Balzac, c'est à 50 ans
qu'on est un vieillard.
Dans le livre
qu'Alfred Sauvy
et le Dr Debré avaient publié,
"Des Français pour la France",
en 1946 chez Gallimard,
à partir de 60 ans,
on était un vieillard.
Ensuite, on est allé
jusqu'à 65 ans.
Maintenant, vous l'avez dit,
c'est 75-80 ans.
Et encore, pas complètement,
j'espère.
Il rit.
C'est important,
dans la mesure où
l'état de santé a aussi suivi
en partie.
Les travaux des économistes
de la santé,
comme Brigitte Dormont
qui montre
quels sont les coûts de santé...
Au lieu de les mesurer
selon l'âge,
elle les mesure
selon l'âge
auquel on décède.
On s'aperçoit
que tout glisse,
d'une certaine manière,
donc c'est...
Je voudrais être plus optimiste.
Quand on prend des limites d'âge
démographiques...
-Vraiment,
je ne voulais pas les prendre.
Elles ne veulent pas
dire grand-chose,
mais ça éclaire un peu.
-Juliette Méadel,
par rapport à ce qui a été dit...
Il y a une police
de la parole.
Il faut être politiquement correct
ou on se fait dénoncer
sur les réseaux sociaux.
A votre avis, il faut parler
des vieux, des gens âgés ?
Quel est le langage approprié
pour satisfaire la doxa
des réseaux sociaux ?
-Je ne suis pas spécialiste
de la doxa des réseaux sociaux.
C'est pas la peine
d'être blessant.
"Les vieux", c'est pas agréable,
surtout que, d'abord,
on pense à soi.
On se dit que, un jour,
ça va arriver.
On peut dire
"les personnes âgées".
Ca me semble respectueux.
Précisément,
moi, je suis frappée...
Quand j'étais en 3e,
on nous apprenait que
la démographie française
évoluait vers une pyramide
qui donnait la part belle
aux personnes âgées,
et c'était déjà
il y a vingtaine d'années.
20 ans plus tard, on s'aperçoit
que les pouvoirs publics,
en tout cas,
au niveau gouvernemental,
n'ont absolument pas
ni vu venir cette situation
que les démographes ont montrée,
ni conçu des outils
de politique publique à la hauteur.
Jérôme Guedj le dit
dans son rapport.
La question du grand âge,
les personnes âgées,
c'est comme
toutes les politiques
sociales.
Ca concerne tous les domaines :
l'éducation, la santé...
-On va en parler.
Vous allez voir.
-Oui, mais c'est un problème
politique massif.
C'est l'éléphant dans la pièce.
-Non,
mais juste un mot
sur la politique.
La politique,
vous en avez fait
et vous en faites.
Vous pensez que,
comme le sujet n'est pas clivant,
c'est une des raisons...
-Non, pas du tout.
Quand on fait une politique
du grand âge,
pour être claire,
c'est pas glamour.
Comme les politiciens s'adressent
à ceux qui votent immédiatement,
plutôt les 30-50-60 ans...
Ils pensent d'abord à eux.
Les 30-50-60 ans,
la première chose
à laquelle ils pensent,
c'est pas le grand âge,
pas tout de suite.
Les politiciens ont
une vision
à courte vue.
Quand on bâtit un programme
pour les présidentielles
- c'est une erreur profonde -
on ne pense pas
à la question du grand âge.
C'est une erreur, je trouve,
et une injustice sociale profonde.
-On va en parler.
M. Michel, vous êtes
le médical, si je puis dire,
de l'étape.
Que pensez-vous de ce qui a été dit,
sans pour autant
vous limiter à un point de vue
thérapeutique ?
-Non, bien sûr.
J'aimerais réagir
à ce que vous avez dit,
M. Guedj.
Pour moi,
le vieillissement commence
à la conception.
En fait,
c'est un long processus.
On est tous dans ce processus,
avec une interaction
entre l'individuel et la société.
On commence vraiment à vieillir
sur le plan individuel
à partir de 45-55 ans.
Toutes les fonctions physiologiques
déclinent à partir
de 45-55 ans.
Il y a un problème majeur.
C'est que les personnes
ne se rendent pas compte
et ne comprennent pas
qu'elles vieillissent.
A un moment donné,
comme elles ne prennent pas
soin d'elles,
un problème majeur peut arriver.
Ce qu'a dit M. Guedj
par rapport à ces notions
de robustesse,
fragilité et dépendance,
c'est très vrai.
J'aimerais agir par rapport
à ce que vous avez dit, madame.
Je pense...
En tout cas, mon expérience,
c'est que les vieux
votent beaucoup plus que les jeunes.
En fait...
-Jusqu'à 75, mais bon...
-Oui, même plus.
J'ai l'impression que,
là, il y a...
Vraiment, moi, je suis,
en tant qu'engagé
dans le domaine
depuis 35 ans environ...
J'avoue que
je suis absolument mécontent
de ce qui se passe
depuis 35 ans.
C'est une vague qui arrive,
qui est absolument déterminée,
et rien n'est fait.
Rien n'est fait.
Je n'arrive pas à le comprendre,
parce que ce sera
la prochaine pandémie.
-Rien n'est fait ?
Il y a quand même
des mesures sociales
qui sont prises partout.
Dans les pays démocratiques,
j'entends.
-Il n'y a pas de conscience
du vieillissement.
Pas de conscience
du vieillissement personnel,
du vieillissement environnemental
et aussi familial,
et puis, il n'y a pas de conscience
du vieillissement
à l'intérieur de la maison,
c'est-à-dire
là où l'on vit.
Ces trois consciences
doivent être absolument
mises en avant,
pour que les personnes
qui sont vieillissantes aujourd'hui
se rendent compte
qu'elles sont en partie actrices
de leur vieillissement.
-Très bien.
Oui, Hervé Le Bras ?
-La question de la conscience,
vous avez raison,
est importante,
parce que, en même temps,
si on prend un regard
sur un assez long terme,
d'énormes progrès ont été faits
sur le vieillissement.
Le livre de Simone de Beauvoir
sur la vieillesse
commence par
"Vieillesse est synonyme
"de pauvreté".
Actuellement,
avec le seuil de pauvreté,
ce sont les personnes âgées
qui ont
la plus faible proportion
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté.
Les jeunes ont
la plus forte.
C'était exactement l'inverse
dans les années 80.
Il faut voir que,
en 1970,
2,6 millions de Français étaient
au minimum vieillesse.
L'année dernière,
il en restait 560 000.
C'est 560 000
de trop,
mais ce qui s'est produit...
Il y a eu
un énorme progrès financier,
mais il n'y a pas eu de conscience,
de distinction
dans les cas les plus graves,
parce qu'il y a
des îlots de pauvreté
très importants, malgré tout.
-Jérôme Guedj ?
-Ce qui me frappe...
Rappelez-vous Jacques Chirac
qui interpellait
sur les conséquences
du réchauffement climatique,
alors que c'était objectivé,
même s'il y a eu
du scepticisme un temps.
"La maison brûle
et on regarde ailleurs."
Je pense que
la maison vieillit
et on regarde ailleurs,
parce que, en effet,
on peut considérer
qu'il y a eu des progrès médicaux,
des progrès du système
de protection sociale.
Le fait qu'il y ait
à peine 8 % de retraités pauvres,
soit en dessous des 14 %
de l'ensemble des Français
et deux fois moins
que nos voisins
européens,
ça, c'est dû
à notre système de retraite,
trop généreux pour certains,
mais ça se traduit
par un des plus faibles
taux de pauvreté.
On aime comparer.
Quand on a quelque chose
qui fonctionne,
autant le dire.
On s'est dit que la question
"retraite égale pauvreté
"et précarité" était traitée,
mais, derrière ça,
il y a toute la question
de la place
des personnes âgées
dans la société.
J'ai un petit désaccord
avec Juliette Méadel.
J'hésite pas
à parler de "vieux",
parce que l'espèce de pudeur
à ne pas nommer les choses...
On dit bien "les jeunes".
On ne dit pas "les juniors".
On nomme les jeunes.
Les vieux...
J'ai écrit un petit livre,
"Plaidoyer pour les vieux",
il y a quelques années,
avec cette idée
de contrecarrer quelque chose
qui rend aussi compliqué
tout ce qu'on appelle
de nos voeux,
qui est de lutter
contre l'invisibilisation
des personnes âgées.
Il y a un phénomène
de retrait du débat public,
de retrait...
Juliette avait raison
de le rappeler.
Aux dernières présidentielles,
ça n'a jamais été
un sujet de débat important,
comme l'immigration, la sécurité,
l'éducation, l'hôpital, etc.
La question du vieillissement
et des conséquences sur la société
a été totalement écartée.
Cette invisibilisation est
à tous les étages.
Moins on voit les vieux,
moins on s'en préoccupe.
Un exemple très parlant.
On est sur une chaîne de télé.
Le CSA,
l'ancêtre de l'Arcom,
il y a quelques années,
avait fait une enquête en regardant,
sur une dizaine d'années,
la présence
des personnes âgées ou des vieux
dans les journaux de 20h
sur les six principales
chaînes de télévision.
C'était 6 % des sujets
dans les journaux de 20h,
quand les personnes âgées
représentent 20 % de la population.
Je veux dire que,
symboliquement,
le fait de ne pas voir
qu'on peut parler
vieillesse et sexualité,
vieillesse et sport,
vieillesse et culture,
vieillesse et faits divers.
Il y en a quelques-uns.
On la cantonnait au sujet
soit de la retraite,
soit d'une maladie,
soit d'une problématique
particulière.
Ca semble anecdotique,
mais quand on veut faire avancer
un débat de société,
il faut donner à voir
ceux qui sont concernés
et entendre leur parole
pour qu'ils puissent
coconstruire cette politique.
-On va pas rester
sur ce ressenti,
mais juste un mot là-dessus,
Juliette Méadel.
-On est dans cette situation,
parce que,
en France et en Europe...
De Gaulle disait :
"La vieillesse est un naufrage."
Ca colle à quelque chose de négatif.
C'est comme quand on veut parler
des personnes...
Je me suis occupée
de victimes d'attentats
ou de catastrophes,
donc qui sont malades, handicapées.
Tout ce qui est douloureux,
difficile,
tout ce qui évoque
de la souffrance,
ça ne se vend pas bien
sur les réseaux, dans les journaux.
Il faut changer complètement
le regard de notre société
sur la personne qui est
en position de fragilité.
Ca, c'est un problème politique.
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut arrêter
de ne mettre en avant
que la force, la jeunesse,
la beauté, la richesse.
C'est le monde à l'envers.
La vraie vie n'est pas
celle-là.
C'est une responsabilité
de qui ?
De celui ou celle
qui sera le futur candidat
à la présidentielle.
-Mais aussi
de toute la société.
-Oui.
On a les gouvernants
qu'on mérite.
C'est aussi à la société
de porter un autre regard.
Quand vous réfléchissez
deux secondes,
à tous les âges de la vie,
on a des moments de fragilité :
quand on est petit,
si on est malade à l'âge adulte
et quand on est plus âgé.
C'est quoi, cette société
où on ne montre que celui
qui est fort et beau ?
Les gens ne votent plus,
car on a l'impression
que le politique ne protège pas
le plus fragile.
-C'est une...
Je trouve cette perception
un peu psychologique
et fort intéressante,
mais il faut
qu'on rentre aussi
dans les problèmes qui se posent.
Alors, M. Michel,
vous qui êtes un médecin,
parmi les sujets de préoccupation
des vieux,
des personnes âgées,
il y a le logement.
Alors, en EHPAD
ou maintien à domicile ?
Les deux solutions
ont leurs avantages
et leurs inconvénients.
Comment se fait la distribution
- je sais que
c'est un mot inélégant,
mais en vérité,
ça se pratique -
alors qu'il y a
une volonté affirmée
- ça, on le constate
dans toutes
les statistiques -
des personnes âgées
à vouloir rester chez elles,
à domicile ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de...
Voilà.
-80 % des personnes âgées,
on pourrait dire
même en Europe,
veulent rester et mourir à domicile.
Le problème, c'est que,
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
vraiment, elles ne font rien
pour essayer que ça se passe bien,
tant sur le plan individuel
que sur le plan
du logement lui-même,
et puis, sur le plan
environnemental,
familial et autre.
Là, il y a une construction
à faire,
qui n'est pas une construction
des dernières années de vie,
mais une construction
de toute la vie.
Je reviens sur ça.
Vous n'êtes pas d'accord.
-Non. Je vous dirai pourquoi.
-Elle exprimera son désaccord,
mais la parole est
à vous, pour le moment.
-Je n'ai rien fait.
-Vous l'avez exprimé
avec votre visage.
Rires
Je suis convaincu de ce que je dis,
mais on va argumenter
tout à l'heure.
Et puis, je pense que
les choix vont
essentiellement dépendre
de la notion de dépendance
ou de perte d'autonomie.
C'est-à-dire que, moi,
je différencie les deux.
La dépendance,
c'est physique.
L'autonomie,
c'est plus l'autonomie
de décision.
Les deux choses ne sont pas
forcément toujours
associées.
Pour la dépendance physique,
vous pouvez un peu
rester à la maison
si vous avez de l'aide.
La perte d'autonomie,
avec ces notions de démence,
majeures,
pose d'autres problèmes.
A mon avis, c'est à ce moment-là,
quand il y a une rupture,
que le domicile n'est plus possible.
-En tant que médecin,
comment vous expliquez...
Moi, en tant que journaliste,
il m'arrive d'interviewer
très fréquemment
certains intellectuels
qui gardent leur tête,
si on peut dire,
même très âgés,
dans des conditions physiques
désavantagées,
tandis que certains,
dans des conditions physiques
désavantagées,
ont aussi leur psychisme
qui vacille.
Comment vous expliquez ça ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait
que le...
-Vaste problème !
-Ah, c'est un problème majeur.
J'aurais le prix Nobel, si je...
-La question se pose.
-C'est aussi un problème
d'éducation.
-On peut perdre son autonomie
physiquement,
mais pas psychiquement,
et vice versa.
-D'où la différenciation
entre dépendance et l'autonomie,
mais je pense que, là...
C'est très compliqué à dire.
Il y a une notion d'éducation
extrêmement importante, à la base,
car elle intervient beaucoup
dans les notions
de perte d'autonomie en particulier
et aussi
de perte de dépendance.
Là, ça intervient beaucoup,
mais ce qu'il faut voir...
Immédiatement après la personne,
il faut voir
l'environnement familial.
L'environnement familial est majeur.
Si vous avez construit votre vie
avec, autour de vous,
des personnes qui sont aimantes,
vous arrivez mieux
à rester à domicile
que s'il n'y a plus personne
autour de vous.
C'est vraiment essentiel.
-Jérôme Guedj, là-dessus ?
-Sur le logement ?
D'abord, encore une fois,
il ne faut pas que
"l'arbre de la dépendance cache
la forêt du vieillissement".
C'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles
on a toujours repoussé
les lois sur le sujet.
Vous l'avez dit en introduction.
L'accompagnement de la perte
d'autonomie,
de la dépendance,
pour ceux qui sont en EHPAD
ou en service
à domicile,
c'est une question
bien planifiée.
Il faut aller chercher de l'argent
dans les 10 prochaines années,
9 à 10 milliards d'euros en plus.
Tous les gouvernements ont freiné
des quatre fers, en se disant :
"On a d'autres priorités."
Pourtant, c'est un sujet majeur.
Aujourd'hui,
le scandale absolu
que nous vivons,
c'est le mode d'organisation
de nos services à domicile,
où on a
300 ou 400 000 professionnels
qui ont des conditions de travail
exécrables.
Ce sont surtout des femmes.
C'est un sujet clivant,
parce que, derrière,
on touche à des sujets
d'organisation du travail,
à un combat féministe.
Les services à domicile,
c'est la dernière activité en France
où il y a une tarification
à l'heure,
parfois à la minute,
avec des situations de précarité,
d'intermittence.
1er scandale.
Le 2e, c'est dans les EHPAD,
et pas uniquement
sur les scandales financiers.
-Un mot là-dessus.
Est-ce que ça s'est amélioré
depuis ce qu'on a appelé
le scandale des EHPAD,
avec le livre de Victor Castanet,
"Les fossoyeurs" ?
Est-ce que ça s'est amélioré ?
-Non.
Ca s'est amélioré
sur le point particulier
qu'il a levé.
C'est la financiarisation,
la manière dont...
-Et la maltraitance ?
-Je vais vous dire
une chose un peu terrible.
La maltraitance est systémique.
Notre société a décidé,
inconsciemment ou non,
de ne pas donner assez de moyens
pour accompagner dignement
les personnes âgées
dans les EHPAD.
J'étais, hier,
dans un EHPAD à Orléans.
Je discutais
avec des aides-soignantes.
Le matin,
elles sont six aides-soignantes
pour s'occuper de 77 personnes.
Ca veut dire que, concrètement,
elles n'ont pas le temps
pour faire la toilette,
pour aider à prendre
le petit-déjeuner.
On est encore, en France,
avec des situations
où on va prendre une douche
tous les 15 jours.
C'est un choix de société
qui a été fait.
Il y a pas assez de personnel
dans les EHPAD,
alors que les besoins
sont gigantesques.
On aura toujours besoin
des EHPAD.
Même si les gens privilégient
le fait de rester à domicile,
il y a certaines situations
de trouble cognitif,
de dément déambulant,
de polypathologie,
qui font que
l'EHPAD sera nécessaire,
mais à condition qu'il soit
un véritable lieu de vie.
L'insuffisance de personnel
fait que c'est à la chaîne,
dans des conditions qui sont
- je le redis -
maltraitantes.
-Hervé Le Bras,
est-ce qu'il y a eu
des études démographiques
qui montrent que des personnes
qui restent à domicile
vivent plus longtemps
que si elles sont trimbalées
dans des EHPAD ?
Est-ce que, ça...
Objectivement,
sans faire de démagogie.
-Objectivement,
comme il y a une sélection
entre ceux qui vont rester
à domicile et les autres,
c'est dur de faire la séparation.
Je voudrais ajouter,
sur ce point-là...
Vous avez dit,
à juste titre,
que le vieillissement se fabrique
tout au long de la vie,
mais il se fabrique,
pas simplement
pour une raison biologique.
C'est par les métiers
qu'ont subis les personnes.
Quand on regarde
les différences d'espérance de vie,
elles sont très importantes
selon la catégorie sociale.
Les ouvriers,
surtout les manoeuvres,
ont actuellement encore,
en France,
sept ans de moins
d'espérance de vie que les cadres.
Ca va beaucoup plus loin.
Quand on regarde la partie
de vie en bonne santé,
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé,
à ce moment-là,
l'écart est
encore plus grand
pour ceux
qui meurent le plus jeunes.
-Oui, mais Hervé Le Bras,
nous avons eu ici, sur ce plateau,
plusieurs fois,
l'économiste Daniel Cohen,
à qui je rends hommage.
-Oui.
-Il dit
cette chose évidente.
Dans nos démocraties...
C'est pire ailleurs,
dans les sociétés totalitaires.
Il dit qu'il y a constamment
des avancées sociales,
mais en même temps,
les inégalités se creusent.
Est-ce qu'on peut espérer un jour
inverser la tendance ?
-Alors, oui, je le pense justement,
et le travail
de Jérôme Guedj va dans ce sens-là.
-On a eu des régimes de gauche
et des régimes de droite...
-Quand on regarde à nouveau...
-...mais les inégalités
n'ont pas été...
-Alors, les inégalités...
Globalement, si vous voulez,
il y a eu une grosse diminution
des inégalités,
pour la France
et la plupart des pays développés,
sauf les Etats-Unis,
jusque vers 2000. Ensuite,
ça s'est lentement inversé,
mais c'est assez lent.
Quand on regarde par âge,
les inégalités,
de façon surprenante,
ne sont pas plus importantes
dans la catégorie
des personnes âgées
que dans celle des actifs,
mais ça veut dire
qu'elles restent
quand même importantes.
Il y a un sentiment,
du fait de la fragilité
des personnes âgées,
qui les rend plus inégales,
mais elles ne le sont pas plus.
-On va avancer.
Je vais vous donner la parole,
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
qui se posent.
On ne peut pas rester
que dans du ressenti
ou du psychologique.
Il y a beaucoup de problèmes.
La transition démographique,
aujourd'hui,
oblige à adapter la société
dans son ensemble.
Sont concernés l'habitat
- on vient
d'en parler -
les transports,
l'accès aux soins, aux loisirs,
à une alimentation,
au numérique, etc.
Comment arbitrer
entre ces différentes adaptations
et lesquelles
ont la priorité ?
Parce qu'on ne peut pas
tout faire dans une société.
Voilà.
-On ne peut pas tout faire,
mais quand même...
-Que faut-il faire d'abord ?
-On doit pouvoir
permettre à quelqu'un
de finir ses jours dignement.
Aujourd'hui,
les conditions dans lesquelles
on finit son existence...
Je ne parle pas
des soins palliatifs.
Je parle des 10 dernières années,
surtout quand on est malade.
Le nombre de maladies
ne cesse d'augmenter,
car on vit
de plus en plus longtemps.
Par ailleurs,
il y a un facteur environnemental
sur les maladies cognitives.
Il y a une population
de plus en plus malade,
avec plus de maladies cognitives,
qui vit
de plus en plus longtemps.
Vous savez que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
a diminué ?
C'est-à-dire qu'elle augmente
en valeur absolue,
mais on sait que, aujourd'hui,
passé 65 ans,
on va de plus en plus mal
et que l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé
est plus courte.
C'est quand même un signe
de dégradation
de nos conditions de vie,
donc, pour moi,
une priorité
pour le prochain président
serait de dire :
"On doit finir ses jours dignement."
Comment on fait ?
Moi, je crois que,
jusqu'à ce qu'on soit dépendant,
le maintien à domicile,
comme le fait le Danemark,
c'est une solution,
mais une solution
très onéreuse.
Rester chez soi,
avoir un maintien à domicile
tant qu'on est à peu près capable,
c'est cher, car il faut des aides.
On n'a pas toujours des parents
pour s'occuper de soi.
On a aussi
des jeunes qui n'ont pas envie
de le faire.
Le maintien à domicile
doit être réorganisé.
Il y a un éclatement
entre départements,
communes...
C'est très compliqué
d'organiser
le maintien à domicile
d'une personne âgée.
Il faut pratiquement
un mi-temps pour coordonner,
avoir les aides, être présent,
ouvrir la porte
aux différents intervenants.
C'est un premier sujet.
Le deuxième sujet,
c'est effectivement les EHPAD.
Il faut changer leur modèle.
Les EHPAD se sont financiarisés,
oui,
mais les grands groupes
à la tête des EHPAD, Orpea en tête,
ne sont pas assez contrôlés.
Il faut, maintenant...
Qui contrôle les EHPAD ?
Les ARS.
Dans les agences régionales
de santé,
il y a trois-quatre inspecteurs
envoyés...
Il y a 23 ARS, en France.
Trois inspecteurs...
-Les ARS,
ce sont les agences régionales
de santé,
effectivement.
-Elles sont en partenariat
avec les départements
et d'autres collectivités locales.
Les ARS sont chargées
de surveiller ce qui se passe.
Elles ne pilotent pas les EHPAD.
Elles doivent surveiller.
Trois inspecteurs par ARS.
Comment l'Etat peut-il contrôler
ce qui se passe ?
La CNSA, le financeur des EHPAD...
C'est la caisse.
La CNSA, la caisse qui paye,
elle n'exerce pas
de pouvoir de contrôle.
-On vous a entendue.
-Qu'est-ce que je dis,
Emile Malet ?
-Vos priorités ?
-Il faut que l'Etat ait
une vision du grand âge,
qu'il contrôle les conditions
dans lesquelles
les personnes âgées
finissent leurs jours,
en particulier dans les EHPAD,
et qu'il surveille
les conditions du bien-être.
-M. Michel,
vos priorités, à vous,
c'est...
Tout va mal,
si je vous entends.
Rires
-Tout va mal,
parce qu'on veut pas, Emile Malet.
-Moi, je pense
qu'il faut commencer
en prenant conscience
de son propre vieillissement
et que la personne soit
responsable.
Je suis vraiment
convaincu de ça.
Autrement,
on peut toujours donner
des solutions pour ci,
pour ça,
mais il faut que la personne,
que chacun
d'entre nous soit conscient
de son vieillissement,
qu'on agisse dans ce sens.
-Et vous, Jérôme Guedj,
vos priorités ?
-Sur les mobilités,
le logement, etc.,
il faut voir la vie,
la ville et les villages
avec un oeil de vieux,
c'est-à-dire mettre les fragilités
et les vulnérabilités
comme porte d'entrée
de la définition des politiques
publiques à mener.
Le vieillissement est
un phénomène territorial.
Il y a des sociodémographes
qui ont bien démontré que,
pour une personne âgée,
ce qui compte,
c'est les services et les biens
auxquels elle a accès
dans un rayon de 500 m
autour de chez elle.
C'est pour ça
que je suis convaincu que
- je parle devant
une élue municipale -
les maires seront
en première ligne
pour coordonner les enjeux
du vieillissement.
Ils n'ont pas
toutes les compétences.
Il y a les ARS, les départements,
les bailleurs sociaux
sur les logements, etc.,
mais les maires vont devoir
se poser cette question :
est-ce que,
sur mon territoire municipal,
on a l'ensemble
de cette adaptation ?
Je vous prends un exemple.
Vous allez comprendre.
Ces dernières années,
dans les villes,
on a retiré les bancs
de l'espace public,
parce que les jeunes
s'y installent
et ils font du bruit.
Parfois, il y a
des sans domicile fixe
et on veut les éloigner,
ce qui n'est pas très sympa.
Conséquence :
il y a moins de bancs.
Avec cette décision qui a été prise
pour une raison
- les jeunes, les SDF -
on a envoyé un message subliminal
aux personnes âgées :
ne sortez pas de chez vous.
Une personne âgée a besoin,
quand elle va se promener,
d'avoir un endroit où elle peut
se reposer.
Comme dans la chanson de Brel,
on leur a dit :
"Du lit au salon,
puis du lit au fauteuil
"et du lit au lit."
Donc, aujourd'hui, concrètement...
Je pense à Mathieu Klein,
le maire de Nancy.
Il a pris ce sujet.
Ca peut paraître bizarre,
mais il a lancé un plan bancs.
Il a posé la question
pour savoir
où réinstaller les bancs,
comment discuter
avec les personnes âgées.
Ils ont fait
des déambulations.
-Vous êtes député.
-Ca semble anecdotique.
-Comment légiférer
face à cette diversité
de problèmes ?
Selon les territoires,
selon les niveaux de revenus,
selon la structure
familiale,
ça ne se pose pas
de la même manière.
-D'abord,
c'est le cadre.
C'est pour ça que j'aime le terme
de transition démographique.
Les deux autres transitions
qui bouleversent
nos sociétés,
les transitions
écologique et digitale,
sont regardées.
Chacun s'en préoccupe :
les entreprises,
les collectivités locales, l'Etat.
La transition démographique,
la révolution de la longévité,
pour l'instant,
c'est pas prioritaire.
La première chose :
provoquer le débat.
Je me suis battu,
avec d'autres,
pour qu'on ait
une loi de programmation
sur le grand âge
et, au-delà du seul grand âge,
sur la longévité.
J'ai élaboré,
pour stimuler le débat,
une proposition de loi
pour garantir le droit
à vieillir dans la dignité
et adapter la société à cela.
Qu'est-ce qu'il devrait y avoir
dans un texte comme ça ?
Parler des compétences
des communes
pour coordonner
les acteurs du vieillissement
sur leur territoire,
parler
de logement.
Dans le parc social,
on va avoir une crise
du vieillissement majeure.
On a des cages d'escalier,
où il y a déjà une majorité de gens
de plus de 60 ans.
Dans les 15 années qui viennent,
car il y a peu de turnover,
on aura une résidence autonomie
sur pied.
Chaque sujet doit être regardé
avec transversalité.
Concernant le financement,
il faut un débat public national,
dans lequel on donne la parole
aux anciens,
parce qu'on ne peut pas
décider pour eux,
même si - et c'est intéressant
avec le vieillissement,
contrairement
à d'autres sujets -
nous sommes tous
des vieux en devenir.
C'est ça qui est passionnant.
Moi,
je milite pour ces sujets,
parce que je pense que
c'est éminemment politique.
J'ai dit que c'était
un combat féministe,
mais c'est aussi
un sujet d'emploi.
C'est des gisements d'emplois,
dès qu'on pourra les financer
et les socialiser.
C'est des emplois
non délocalisables,
non substituables,
les métiers du lien, du soin,
de l'accompagnement.
Il y a un enjeu
d'aménagement du territoire.
Il y a des pans entiers
du territoire national
où on est dans une crise
du vieillissement.
On parle de déserts médicaux,
mais il y a des déserts
médico-sociaux.
On ne peut plus recruter
dans les EHPAD ni à domicile.
Donc c'est un enjeu
pouvoir d'achat, combat féministe,
aménagement du territoire,
emploi, santé...
Si ça, c'est pas politique...
Sur tous ces sujets,
c'est des choix clivants à faire.
C'est plus de solidarité familiale
ou nationale ?
Des services publics
ou des opérateurs privés ?
Comment on finance ?
Chacun pour soi ou bien...
Moi, je propose par exemple
d'augmenter
les impôts sur les successions
pour financer le grand âge.
Ce débat va être passionnant,
à condition qu'il ait lieu...
-Donc vous,
vous serez d'accord
pour qu'il y ait un grand emprunt,
par exemple, pour le grand âge ?
-Je sais pas
si c'est un emprunt
qu'il faut faire...
-Vu les déficits !
-Pour le coup
on va alimenter l'âgisme en disant :
"C'est à cause des vieux."
Je suis attaché à la logique
de la Sécurité sociale,
un objectif universel.
-Je voudrais votre avis,
Hervé Le Bras,
sur un point important.
Si je vous écoute,
le grand âge,
c'est une diversité de situations,
c'est d'abord,
sur le plan sanitaire,
les santés ne sont pas les mêmes,
sur le plan territorial,
les logements...
Il y a des gens qui vivent jusqu'à
100 ans en très bon état
et il y en a à 60 ans
qui sont déjà dépendants.
Démographiquement, comment on peut
faire des projections
à partir
d'une telle diversité
de situations ?
-Très difficile, oui.
La plus simple projection,
- on en parlait
avec le docteur Michel -
on ne sait pas très bien
comment va évoluer
l'espérance de vie,
donc la mortalité,
au cours des 10 ou 15
prochaines années.
Il y a eu un ralentissement
à partir à peu près de 2010-2012,
pas simplement en France,
en Angleterre,
encore plus aux Etats-Unis.
Ca change énormément de choses
en termes de volumes
de personnes âgées,
donc c'est très difficile.
En plus de ça,
des questions se recoupent.
-Comment les politiques
peuvent se projeter
si les scientifiques...
-Ma réponse serait
à peu près la même
que pour la question
des retraites.
Ce serait d'abord
de définir précisément...
Pour la retraite, par exemple,
la question était celle
de la politique juste.
Il fallait définir.
J'ai entendu dire
par le gouvernement
que les mesures étaient justes.
En quoi étaient-elles justes ?
Une proposition, c'est de dire
qu'une juste retraite,
c'est que le nombre d'années
travaillées donne droit
à la même espérance de vie
en bonne santé à la retraite.
C'est l'exemple
de justice.
Or, par exemple,
à propos
de ce que vous signaliez
à propos de la mobilité,
quelque chose de simple,
c'est de dire
qu'il faut une égalité
de mobilité,
que les personnes âgées
puissent se déplacer dans la ville
aussi bien que les autres.
Il faut poser
des termes clairs
et simples.
Et juste un tout petit point
à propos du logement.
On entre dans des contradictions.
Vous avez parlé de vieillissement,
vous avez raison,
mais les personnes âgées
restent dans leurs logements.
Quand on regarde comment évolue
le nombre moyen de personnes
par logement en fonction
du nombre de pièces,
on voit que ça monte,
et arrivé à 50-70 ans,
ça reste à peu près au niveau.
Et le gros problème
de l'habitat social,
c'est de faire passer
les personnes
qui sont dans des logements
de 3 à 4-5 pièces
dans des logements de 2 pièces.
-Merci, Hervé Le Bras.
On va passer au moment
anthropologique.
Je voudrais parler
de vieillissement et d'amour
à partir d'une histoire
que m'a relatée Elie Wiesel,
l'ancien prix Nobel de la paix.
Un jour, il visitait un cimetière
en Amérique latine.
Et il était intrigué
par le fait que sur les tombes,
il y avait des visages
très jeunes et il ne comprenait pas
pourquoi tous ces morts
avaient sur leur tombe
des espèces de petits camées
avec des visages très jeunes.
Alors il a interrogé
le gardien du cimetière :
"Comment se fait-il
que dans ce cimetière,
"les gens, comme partout ailleurs,
c'est des personnes âgées
"qui sont décédées, mais les visages
ne correspondent pas ?"
Et le gardien lui a dit :
"Dans ce cimetière,
"on ne met pas la photo
"du défunt quand il est âgé,
mais on lui demande
"combien d'âge d'amour il avait."
Donc certains avaient quelques
jours, d'autres, quelques années.
Donc je voudrais vous intéresser
et vous faire parler de ce sujet-là.
Les vieux et les jeunes,
c'est des mondes qui se côtoient
mais qui se distinguent.
Les valeurs sont pas les mêmes.
Il y a une instantanéité,
il y a la rapidité,
il y a une hyper modernité
chez les jeunes
et il y a un côté sagesse
chez les personnes âgées, etc.
Ils diffèrent
par leur rapport à l'intimité,
au temps, etc.
Comment fait-on pour appréhender
ces générations
sans les séparer ?
Jérôme Guedj.
-C'est précisément...
Dans votre introduction,
vous avez utilisé le terme
de guerre des âges.
S'il y a bien une guerre
à éviter dans ce pays...
On a suffisamment de lignes
de fractures, voilà,
sur les questions religieuses,
sociales, etc.
Donc ne nous ajoutons pas
une guerre des âges,
qui peut nous pendre au nez
avec la question de savoir
si on n'en fait pas trop
pour les vieux.
C'est parfois ce qui retient
le législateur ou le gouvernement
de dégager des moyens :
"Les baby-boomers ont déjà profité
du boom de l'immobilier, etc."
On va pas encore en plus
leur en rajouter.
Regardez ce qui s'est passé
pendant le Covid.
C'était l'inquiétude
qu'on pouvait avoir.
On a quand même confiné
pour protéger les plus vulnérables,
et la bonne nouvelle,
c'est qu'on n'a pas eu une sorte
d'insurrection âgiste.
Il y a eu un ou deux acteurs
dans le débat public,
comme André Comte-Sponville
ou François de Closets,
qui avait dit : "C'est scandaleux
de confiner pour des vieillards
"qui vont mourir dans les six mois."
Donc il faut absolument
éviter cette guerre des âges,
et ça passe par les liens
intergénérationnels.
Les personnes âgées,
c'est des vecteurs de transmission,
de mémoire,
de sagesse, de tempérance,
des valeurs dont on a besoin
dans nos sociétés.
Et ça passe précisément
par le fait d'organiser ces liens.
-Hervé Le Bras, sur cet aspect
de rapport au temps
et même ces questions d'amour.
-En fait, la situation,
je vais être à nouveau optimiste,
est très bonne, en France.
Dans les enquêtes,
on pose la question sur la famille :
96 % des Français pensent
que la famille se porte bien,
qu'elle est une valeur importante.
C'était pas la même chose
dans les années 30.
C'était : "Famille, je vous hais,
quittez la famille,
"une chambre en ville."
Je dirais même que c'est pas
simplement un problème en France.
Il y a eu un certain repli
sur la famille.
C'est le slogan :
"Malheur public, bonheur privé."
Vous l'avez entendu,
notamment à cause
d'une certaine déception
vis-à-vis de la politique.
Donc il y a là-dedans, au fond,
un thème d'espoir.
Ca n'empêche pas qu'il y ait
des personnes...
La plus grande injustice,
c'est qu'il y a des personnes
qui ont beaucoup de famille
et d'autres
qui en ont peu.
L'Etat a été créé pour égaliser
ces situations
individuelles.
-Juliette Méadel,
je reviens sur ma question initiale,
à la fois sur la citation
de Philippe Torreton
et sur l'histoire d'Elie Wiesel.
Quel rapport on peut faire
entre les personnes âgées
et cet amour
qui est associé
à cette génération,
comme porteuse d'amour
pour les jeunes générations ?
-Je suis pas très friande
de généralités
parce que je crois
que ce qui détermine la relation
entre un petit enfant
et ses grands-parents,
c'est le transgénérationnel,
c'est ce que le grand-parent
a transmis à l'enfant
puis au petit-enfant.
Les liens de famille
sont irréductiblement liés
à l'intime, à l'individu,
à son histoire, à sa spécificité.
Le politique a pas grand-chose
à faire là-dedans.
Là où le politique
peut faire des choses,
c'est sur l'éducation,
apprendre qu'on doit prendre soin
du plus vulnérable.
Qui est le plus vulnérable ?
Dans la sphère familiale,
c'est le malade, l'handicapé,
la personne âgée,
mais c'est d'abord sur le terrain
de la solidarité nationale,
familiale, que peut se porter
le discours du politique.
L'amour dont vous parliez
ne s'apprend pas dans des lois.
L'amour, c'est quelque chose
qui se transmet,
qui est lié à ce que vous êtes,
mais la solidarité,
c'est une obligation civique,
si je puis dire, et ça,
ça relève du politique.
-Monsieur Michel, là-dessus ?
-Je suis entièrement d'accord
avec ce que vous dites.
La chose qu'il faut
qu'on réapprenne,
c'est à vivre tous ensemble.
Et ça, on ne l'a plus,
actuellement.
Il faut penser aux sociétés
dans d'autres continents,
qui ont encore la personne âgée
comme la personne importante
de la famille.
Chez nous, c'est pas le cas.
-Vous dites qu'il faut apprendre
à vivre ensemble,
or,
ce que l'on constate aujourd'hui,
c'est exactement le contraire.
Vous avez un clivage selon les âges,
selon les sexes,
selon les genres,
selon les options politiques,
selon les fantasmes,
selon les mythes, etc.
Comment, dans ce cadre-là,
et en même temps,
avec une distribution
des valeurs qui sont distinctes,
comment faire, dans ce cadre ?
-Ce que vient de dire
madame Méadel est important,
parce qu'au sein de la famille,
la personne âgée est encore intégrée
et fait partie de la famille.
Donc il y a peut-être
des distinctions
au niveau global et général,
mais au sein de chaque famille,
il y a ce respect, dans l'ensemble,
et cette notion
d'intergénérationnalité
est vraiment importante...
-Je vais mettre en cause
le politique avec Jérôme Guedj,
là-dessus.
Les barrières d'âge, les politiques
portent une responsabilité,
les syndicats aussi.
Je vais vous dire,
vous prenez certaines professions
très capées,
intellectuellement,
scientifiquement,
à 65 ans, quand elles partent
à la retraite,
elles sont toujours très capées
et très capables,
et elles pourraient faire
du tutorat, etc.
Les barrières d'âge,
on n'arrive pas à les franchir.
-Je vais être dans le prolongement
de ce que j'ai dit
en dénonçant l'âgisme potentiel.
L'âgisme, c'est cette discrimination
liée à l'âge, de droit ou de fait.
Il faut la combattre
avant qu'elle débouche
sur une guerre des âges.
Les barrières d'âge,
c'est l'incarnation palpable
de cette forme de séparation.
Dès qu'on entend "barrières d'âge",
il faut faire gaffe, c'est dire
que passé un certain âge,
vos droits reculent.
Ca peut paraître
contre-intuitif
pour un homme de gauche,
mais je suis hostile
à l'existence
de barrières d'âge.
Si quelqu'un veut continuer
à travailler au-delà
d'un certain âge,
il y a des limites dans la fonction
publique et dans le privé,
parce qu'à partir de 70 ans,
votre employeur peut légalement
vous licencier au nom de votre âge.
Ca n'existe pas dans le libéral.
On a des médecins, des avocats,
des notaires, des huissiers
qui peuvent continuer.
On supprime les barrières d'âge
dans le rapport au travail.
-Ca va...
-Mais on n'en introduit pas
dans de nouveaux dispositifs.
Je prends un exemple sur l'âgisme.
A chaque fois qu'il y a
une personne âgée, un octogénaire,
qui prend un contre-sens
et qui provoque un drame
sur la route avec un accident,
on a le débat
dans les émissions de radio
ou dans les journaux :
faut-il retirer le permis
ou faire repasser le permis
de conduire passé un certain âge ?
Ca, c'est de l'âgisme.
Qu'on pose la question
pour nous tous,
parce qu'on peut avoir des problèmes
de santé à 50-60-70 ans,
de savoir si on doit pas
voir régulièrement,
parce qu'on a passé le permis
à 18 ans, et que 50 ou 60 ans après,
ce serait pas incongru
pour nous tous et toutes
d'avoir une petite évaluation.
Donc le droit commun,
mais pas de stigmatisation
liée à l'âge,
parce que ça participe
de ce que j'évoquais, la relégation,
l'invisibilisation
des personnes âgées.
-Oui ?
-Ce que vous dites est vrai
pour le rapport à l'emprunt.
Aujourd'hui, passé un certain âge,
mais pas âgé,
au-delà, je crois,
de 60 ou 65 ans...
-Les conditions sont...
-Même avant.
Quand vous voulez emprunter
pour acheter une voiture,
à 60 ou 65 ans, plus personne
ne vous prête d'argent.
C'est quasiment une atteinte
à votre autonomie, à votre dignité,
alors que vous pouvez être
en parfaite santé.
Vous avez payé des impôts,
travaillé toute votre vie,
vous êtes en bonne santé
et le système financier bancaire,
qui ne prend jamais de risque,
vous dénie le droit
de vous endetter.
-Politiquement, vous êtes aussi...
-On devrait interdire ça.
-On est d'accord.
Mais pour franchir
les barrières d'âge,
permettre des tutorats...
-Mais je crois que les barrières
d'âge ne doivent pas exister.
François Hollande
avait inventé en 2012
le contrat de génération.
On avait travaillé sur cette idée
qu'il pouvait y avoir,
dans une entreprise,
un sénior qui accompagnait
un jeune.
Ca a jamais bien fonctionné.
Mais il faut travailler
cette idée de solidarité
transgénérationnelle.
Aujourd'hui,
plein de personnes à la retraite,
en pleine forme, font du bénévolat,
parce que d'abord ça les maintient,
qui transmettent,
et je suis pour qu'on les encourage,
qu'on les valorise,
et qu'on l'érige comme un modèle,
d'être dans la société,
d'être actif.
-Aux Etats-Unis,
si vous prenez les universités,
il n'y a pas de limite d'âge
pour un universitaire.
Et en même temps, on s'aperçoit
qu'ils partent à un âge
relativement jeune,
entre 65 et 70 ans.
-En tout cas,
pour cette émission,
on n'a pas fait
de ségrégation d'âge.
Ils rient.
Je voudrais écouter...
L'auteur de ces mots
s'y implique également.
On va terminer,
puisqu'il nous reste
très peu de temps,
et pour donner un peu d'espoir etc.
Dans la vie des personnes âgées,
au-delà des améliorations
socio-économiques
dont on a parlé pendant cette heure,
il y a des choses
qui sont moins utilitaires,
peut-être plus ludiques,
qui font retour
à ce qu'un philosophe appelait
un "presque rien".
Quelque chose
qui donne de la vie à la vie.
A votre avis,
quelle aération vous donneriez
pour changer la vie,
en quelque sorte ?
Je ne vous demande pas
de créer de nouveaux impôts,
on en a parlé.
Là, on est dans...
-Moi, je suis...
Je suis vraiment médecin
et je vois le parcours de vie.
Je n'arrive pas à me concentrer
sur le grand âge.
Je vois ça en parcours de vie.
Et dans ce parcours de vie,
la chose qui est la plus importante
et qui est
la nouvelle définition du vieillir
en bonne santé, c'est être
fonctionnellement actif
jusqu'au bout
pour avoir un bien-être
au grand âge.
Et, pour moi,
la notion de maladie
n'existe plus,
elle est surpassée
par la notion de fonctionnalité
tout au long de la vie.
-Bien.
Juliette Méadel,
là-dessus ?
Je voudrais l'idée d'âge
à l'idée
de plénitude.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'on est vieux
qu'on est malheureux.
On peut très bien être bien portant
ou mal portant mais heureux,
c'est-à-dire apaisé,
jusque dans les derniers moments
de sa vie.
C'est une question de...
de psychologie,
d'accompagnement, de valeurs
et ça se travaille dans nos discours
politiques et de société.
-Oui, Jérôme Guedj ?
-La vieillesse n'est pas
une maladie.
Il faut marteler cela.
La vieillesse est une chance
et le vieillissement
de la population,
c'est une chance
pour notre pays.
Ca ne doit pas être vécu
comme un boulet,
comme quelque chose d'anxiogène.
C'est un défi
- et je me mets
sous l'angle de la décision
de la puissance publique -
auquel nous devons nous adapter,
que nous devons anticiper
et inciter, je suis d'accord, chacun
à avoir la lucidité de regarder
son propre vieillissement
pour le préparer
dans de bonnes conditions.
-Hervé le Bras,
en deux mots ?
-Un petit peu en rebours :
ne pas croire que les personnes
âgées étaient bien traités
dans l'ancien temps.
C'était horrible.
Un grand nombre de travaux
d'anthropologie historique
sur le 18e siècle
montrent comment dans la Lozère,
on les plaquait contre une porte
jusqu'à ce qu'elles étouffent,
comment elles étaient chassées
du logis en Picardie.
Mon souhait, c'est de dire :
reconnaissons qu'on a quand même
fait des progrès
même s'il reste beaucoup
à faire.
-Merci de cette note d'optimisme.
Il me reste à vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Jérôme Guedj,
vous avez publié rapport sur rapport
concernant les personnes âgées
et vous avez également publié
un "Plaidoyer pour les vieux".
Cette question,
ça a stimulé chez vous
un côté littéraire
qui vous a poussé à écrire ?
-Euh...
-On n'a pas beaucoup de temps,
je sais, la question est
importante mais...
-En tous les cas, de participer
à l'alimentation du débat public,
y compris
dans la culture populaire.
C'est assez intéressant.
Dans le roman, dans le cinéma,
dans les séries,
on voit de plus en plus,
et c'est tant mieux,
des personnes âgées,
et c'est aussi une manière
de participer
de cette reconnaissance
et de cette participation
à la vie de la cité.
-Hervé Le Bras,
vous avez publié
un "Atlas des inégalités"
chez Autrement-Flammarion,
et c'était pour montrer
cette persistance.
En même temps,
vous dites que ça s'améliore
pour les personnes âgées.
-Oui, sur le long terme.
Mais c'est surtout...
Dans cet atlas,
on voit surtout,
on en a peu parlé,
qu'il y a de fortes différences
géographiques.
C'est le but d'un atlas.
On pourrait aussi parler...
qu'il y a une montée
d'une ségrégation des âges
qui est un autre problème,
à la fois dans les villes
mais aussi entre régions.
-Je voudrais
signaler l'ouvrage
de Philippe Torreton, "Mémé"
chez l'Iconoclaste,
dont on a eu un film
qui est passé...
je crois
que c'était sur France 2.
Est-ce que vous avez un livre
à suggérer ?
-Je vous recommande
un rapport
de la Cour des comptes
qui porte sur les soins palliatifs.
Je vous le recommande, il a été
remis à l'Assemblée nationale,
nous l'avons remis,
et il insiste
sur la question
de l'accompagnement
psychologique des derniers jours
et dont le maître mot est :
permettre de mourir
le plus sereinement possible.
-A bon entendeur,
salut !
Et monsieur Michel ?
-Moi, j'ai été responsable
d'un groupe européen
pour les fédérations européennes
des académies de médecine
qui a été publié en 2019
et qui s'appelle
"Transformer le futur
du vieillissement"
et qui est essentiellement ciblé
sur ce que j'ai dit,
le vieillissement
en bon fonctionnement.
-Eh bien,
pour nos téléspectateurs, voilà
de bonnes lectures.
Il vous reste à vous remercier,
madame, messieurs,
d'avoir participé à cette émission.
Merci à notre équipe de LCP
qui a permis sa réalisation
et, avant de vous laisser,
je vous soumets cette citation :
"Vieillir est encore
le seul moyen qu'on ait trouvé
"de vivre longtemps."
C'est de Sainte-Beuve.
Ils rient.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA